DiBona: So...we're here
doing an interview.
Liu: We are.
We are here to get
nuggets of insight
from Chris DiBona.
DiBona: Little chunklets.
Liu: Just little ones.
Because we can't handle
anything more.
But first we have to ask
about the Chrome comic.
>> DiBona: I should point out
when I heard they were doing
comic, I was like...really?
A comic?
Are you sure?
They were like, yeah.
I was like, okay.
And he, uh, made my goatee
very smooth, you know?
Liu: It's very, uh...
DiBona: Sweet...
Liu: Yeah.
DiBona:
That the internet it.
There were a lot of great
parodies, actually,
of that Chrome comics.
>> Liu: So how's--the feedback's
been very positive from Chrome.
DiBona: I think people seem
to like it, yeah.
There's been already a couple
of really interesting products
that have taken the Chrome code
and done different things
with it
which I thought
was really very positive.
There's already a ton of people
out there patching.
sending patches in to Chrome
to fix things.
In fact, we think
there's more patchers now
than there are employees.
Of course, they don't have
the same kind of output.
I mean, we're just talking
individual bug fixes,
but it's pretty impressive
that, you know,
we're able to look at that many
people that fast.
Liu: Yeah, so...
DiBona: I mean, not all patches
are appropriate for us
to accept but, yeah.
Liu: So obviously this was
a very, you know,
secretive project for a while,
and then you kinda like
just put it out there.
So again, companies
get flack sometimes
for like throwing code
over the wall...
DiBona: Sure, sure.
So it's funny, you know.
We actually have these
great internal debates
about when it's okay
to release some source code.
Is it okay to just release it
and forget about?
Is it okay to release it and not
have a big deal around it?
Or should they all be heavy,
you know, sorta lots of people
working on building a community
and all the rest?
I think the answer is you should
do all of those things, right?
If you look at most
open source projects,
99% of them
is one person working on
a code base in the public,
and they get no help.
They get no bug fixes.
They barely get the users.
And then you have
small sets of those,
they try a couple
of extra developers,
couple extra bug fixers.
And thus, a community, right?
And then you have others
that are,
frankly,
incredibly unusual
like Linux Chrome,
like Samba, like Mozilla...
which are incredibly large,
with thousands of developers,
thousands of people
working on them.
And those are not the norm.
Liu: What was the choice--
like what went into
the decision to...
hey, we're gonna make
this browser.
Why don't we just open up
a project on code
and then develop
a new open for the entire way?
DiBona: So with Chrome,
you know, ask Glen,
as he can probably
answer it best.
But there are times
when they release projects
that are, um...you know...
you know,
being developed in-house
in a very focused manner,
you know, for years,
you know, in the case of
Chrome and Android both.
I think they're both more than
two years old, those efforts.
And so, you know,
they want to basically
to tie performance,
tie performance reviews,
tie employees to the product.
And...and that's not...
something that's incompatible
with open sourcing,
by any measure.
But there is a level of...
"we just wanna do this work
ourselves for a while" goin' on.
We're actually--
we're not really under control.
Control takes a lot of work.
Man: Right.
I firmly believe the only way
to establish control
in open source is not through
the use of restrictive licensing
and not through any sort of
tricks around that.
I firmly believe
that the way you have control
and the way you have leadership
in open source
is by showing intelligent
technical leadership
on a project.
So as long as the Chrome team
at Google, you know,
makes the right decisions
technically for the product,
they're gonna be
in charge of Chrome
and Chromium, right?
Chromium meaning
the open source...
Man: Open source.
DiBona:...version of Chrome
that Chrome is built from.
So...with that said,
if people decide that Google
isn't giving that leadership,
then they will fork and
they'll create something else.
You know, probably call it
Technicium or something.
Whatever, you know?
Come up with something
I want to name it after.
And, um, the thing is
that's okay.
That's a healthy thing.
That's something we wanna
actually encourage as a company
so when we release things
like Chrome,
we're doing it to make
the internet better.
We're not doing it to build
market share for Google.
We're doing it to make the
internet a free and fair place,
a place that can really
exist in a world
where people are used to
responsiveness and functionality
in desktop applications.
So...if people
take our technology
and advance that strategy,
great.
We're very happy.
Same with Android, you know?
It's like, you know, if people
don't like Android
and they wanna change it
and make it better
for their customers,
well, that's good for the idea
of a free and fair
and open cellular phone
operating system
and cellular phone
marketplace as well.
Which is good for Google,
right?
So we feel that we compete
quite well
in free and fair markets
like the internet
and like free and open
cell phones.
So that's why we're releasing
this technology.
So if somebody says
that they can do that
even better than we can...
that serves us.
It does well in my eyes.
So we try to encourage anyone.
But, yes, there's some things
we strategically decided
not to release.
GFS is one of them.
And so what we do instead
in those cases
is we try to ensure
that people are publishing.
So, for instance, Jeff Dean
and Sanjay Ghemawat
have done papers on GFS,
MapReduce, uh, BigTable.
You know, Luiz Barroso did
a paper on, you know,
drive lifetimes.
And if they're read
by technical people,
they can come up with these
technologies fairly rapidly.
And, in fact, that's happened
in the open source world
with Hadu and with HBase
and with some of the other
things that we've created.
So I'm actually really happy
about this, you know?
I think it's really important
that actually
GFS has an open source
competitor.
Because it both keeps us
honest,
but also, if it gets
better than what we have,
we can just adopt it.
Man: Exactly.
DiBona: So we don't feel
competitive with Hadu.
But the other side of this is
is there's some software
that if we release, we make
the internet worse, right?
And that would be like
if we released, uh,
the information of how
we do web ranking,
page ranking
for the web search.
Then web spammers
would get hold of it,
and that would be
a very big problem.
And not just for Google,
but for Yahoo and Microsoft
as well.
Well, I firmly believe,
and quality numbers bear out,
that Google gives the best
search on the internet.
And part of that has to do
with how we look at these people
who abuse the internet
and change how those results
are displayed to end users.
So if we were to let
that information out,
it would make things very,
very bad for not just us
but for Yahoo
and Microsoft too.